obviously you have been the center of
some drama at paradise which is an
understatement there's been a lot going
on what was your reaction when you were
watching it back and and seeing brendan
and piper openly talking about their
following and their followers and how
paradise would be a vacation not a lot
of followers so you're welcome well i
did too like almost 10 000. that's
insane that you have ten thousand
followers
i remember when i hit 70. i was like 70
whatever
i had like
70
8 something
the best part is like the amount of
times your name is going to be brought
up before you're on the show i was very
surprised because for me it was so much
more than that for me personally so and
of course i wasn't privy to any of those
conversations so
i just knew what was going on between us
you know between brandon and i
and of course i didn't know all the
other side conversations just to hear
you know some of the hurtful things that
he said when
i feel like i had been nothing but so
sweet to this man i was just getting so
annoyed
i am
surprised she's like still
here all the little conversations that
him and i have had about life about love
about our families all the deep things
that we talked about
was just for followers was just to wait
for this person to come it just felt
very empty
and i didn't i didn't think that's what
that was and it was like okay we have
this emotional connection that i felt
that i think that i thought he felt as
well and there were just things that i
could feel that he was holding back
um
and i just thought that that was because
he wanted to take things low because he
was you know married before and all
these different things that he was
telling me
and i didn't realize because you know
you get on that beach and you don't have
all the resources in the world that you
have in normal life right
so you just trust what someone says and
i really didn't think that he was
waiting for piper and that was you know
that was stupid on my part
could you know how could you know you
know because it was clear to the
audience it was clear to me that he was
down playing his relationship with piper
uh but do you feel like when you watched
it back he was downplaying his
relationship with you 100 percent and he
very much in my opinion wanted to get
there you know he talked about us not
having a romantic relationship but him
and demi had a romantic relationship but
he didn't want to give her the emotional
part me and him had an emotional but
then he didn't want to give the romantic
part you know it's like he didn't want
to because he had already had strong
feelings for someone else and i get that
and it just sucks that it was to my to
my
um expense what bs from those two
surprised you the most
honestly um
the disregard for a human there's a
disregard for me it's like he literally
told her i had to do things and navigate
things in a way to stay here i think
you're doing all the heavy lifting for
me so i can just like swoop in here
and pave the way
and
clearly i was the casualty there was
never ever a well how do you think
natasha feels and well what about
natasha that
was the most like shocking awful thing
in my opinion if either piper or brendan
reached out to you and apologized would
you be willing to have that conversation
i would have
before all of these failed attempts at
oh my gosh i'm losing followers this is
what it seems like to me i'm losing
followers i'm losing this i'm losing
that i should say something now it just
seems like well what
and and i have i am not a person who is
like vengeful or this or that or
anything like that
i just know that you have to keep toxic
people out of your life and once i
realized how toxic he was and i think
that was the way that i could have the
conversation with him the way that i did
because i realized like wait
he clearly is
being this way you just you can't engage
that's how i deal with it you can't
engage you can't do it and just all the
failed attempts all the the things that
they posted on instagram every action
that they did after this stuff filmed i
mean hey if they would have just posted
a picture together like hey i know this
episode sucked we're sorry but we're in
love and we love each other and we wish
natasha the best well i would have been
like i would have been right there like
go ahead y'all yeah it sucked it was
awful but
feeding into the villain roll just
everything that they did it was like
y'all really don't care
that i was the casualty in this they did
not care they just weren't open she said
she clearly was there for him she didn't
want to date anybody else got it cool
great him
you have romance with jimmy but you
don't want to be anything more than that
you have emotional with me but you
didn't try to be anything more than that
so you have because you already had both
of those things with someone in the real
world so just go explore that and i
really do hope that because it seems
like they belong together
i mean come on like at this point right
yeah i know right here's hoping that at
least works out i mean can we at least
get a love story out of this yeah so if
they dm'd you you would leave them on
red
at this point
no thanks you gained over 178 000
followers and counting in just one day
from last monday to tuesday's episode
and brendan almost lost 60k in one night
what did that when you heard that what
was your reaction did it kind of feel
like validation
at first i was like i didn't want any of
this
you know like i didn't want this to
happen but for everyone watching for the
viewers or bachelor nation for everyone
to really feel how i felt when
everything transpired and they really
stood behind me i was like wow this is
insane like i've never seen anything
like it before i couldn't believe it
well listen you did get your redemption
though let's talk about that special
rose ceremony where of course wells
decided to give an extra rose she was
all in for one person
that just wasn't honest with her this
rose right here
is for a second shot at love that you
deserve
natasha
come on down i was not expecting it i
was fully prepared to be like okay guys
this was cool but paradise was a bus for
me it's awful i got played whatever
so he just really touched my heart in so
many ways and um
and i have a really like he's just
really awesome he's just a really
awesome person and um i i was shocked i
was gonna say was there anybody else
that you were interested in like if
brendan was honest with you that he was
there for piper and waiting for her to
walk down those steps how different
would your experience have been
well
i think it would have been different in
the sense that i would have tried to go
for someone else but also
i would have been fine going home if i
didn't have and wasn't creating this
authentic connection with someone
because that's what i was truly there
for for an authentic connection with
someone fans are now campaigning for you
to be the next bachelorette how do you
feel about that
i mean it is overwhelming it is so
overwhelming it is something that i
never ever even thought about right
um but it's so nice because i think that
people didn't see much of my personality
in on peter's season and they're seeing
a little more of it on on this season
and just how i am and and how i lead
with my heart um and dating's not easy
for me and that's one of the reasons why
i've been on a dating show tasha you
know and her success story with with
zach and then rachel lindsay with brian
i mean you know women of color have a
good track record as bachelorette let's
just say that you really do though right
okay so you'll be ready and willing if
you got the call if they called me i
mean you guys got to see the rest of
what happens on paradise you do have to
stay tuned and see what happens but
if something happened in the future
where i was single and i got a call i
would i would with bells and whistles ho
and hoping
i'd be calling tata and rachel be the
first people i call